what's going on guys my two favorite
seasons are here bikini season and
summer movie season that's right and
that means it's time for our summer box
office predictions and we have an
esteemed panel to predict with first she
is the reigning summer box office movie
prediction champion from clever movies
Erin Robinson
she is our very first summer movie box
office predictions champion sheath film
critic of the LA Weekly Amie Nicholson
and you know him as the undefeated movie
fights champion make some noise for mr.
Dan Merle summer box office summer movie
season kind of getting kicked off with
age of Ultron let's just get it out of
the way we all have Avengers 2 age of
Ultron as our number one choice there's
gonna be movies on this top 10 I think
that aren't gonna make as much in their
entire run as age of Ultron makes in its
first weekend so aside from Avengers 2
age of Ultron you've each made 9
additional choices these are the 10
films that our panelists believe will
have the highest domestic gross of the
summer first up is Erin Robinson she is
the highest on Tomorrowland putting it
at number 5 she's the only one to have
Fantastic Four on her list putting in at
number 7 and she's one of two people to
have Magic Mike double XL cracking her
top 10 next up is Aimee Nicholson along
with Erin Robinson she has ant-man
ranked at number 3 and she's going out
on a limb picking two films that no one
else has on their list melissa mccarthy
comedy spy and Meryl Streep's Riki in
the flash next up is Dan Merle he has
Tomorrowland at numbers
six he's the lowest on ant-man putting
it at number nine and along with Aaron
he's got Magic Mike double XL cracking
his top ten and finally my list the
correct list I'm betting on Adam Sandler
and Peter Dinklage putting pixels at
number 10 I'm the highest on terminator
genisys putting it at number five and
I'm the lowest on minions putting it all
the way down at number three I'd like to
start off by talking about some outliers
that people have on their lists let's
start with you Aaron one film that you
have on your list that no one else has
picked Fantastic Four tell me about your
faith in Fantastic Four well I think the
trailers have looked good and I do think
that people are curious I'm at least
curious to see it why did each of you
omit Fantastic Four at the number 10
spot and then I made my last minute
switch to my own personal number 10 pick
and I realized I don't wanna put another
superhero film in there I think that
there's a market for different types I'm
making a bold guess with my 10 you
picked a movie at number 10 that wasn't
even close to being on my radar Ricky
and the flash talk to me about Ricky and
the flash starring Meryl Streep every
August there's like a really strong
movie that performs great among women
this I think is gonna be the one this is
gonna be like the Mamma Mia you know I
don't think it's gonna be as big as
Mamma Mia but that audience is gonna
come see miles sing again Terminator
Genisys Dan what are your thoughts the
first trailer I was intrigued by the
second trailer I was like oh no no no no
thank you
Terminator is worn out most of its
goodwill it's kind of like oh that
friend that's been crashing on your
couch a little bit too long it's like oh
terminators back ok but you know what
we've been friends for so long I'll see
it ant-man talk to me about ant-man I
don't think a man is gonna be as big as
guardians of the galaxy but I think
Evans gonna get an Ultron boost which
will help get it to the top of the rest
of the superhero pack but I think people
are gonna think ant-man is a slight bit
of a disappointment people would seem to
be hedging on ant-man dan what are your
thoughts I'm one of the ones that's
hedging on a man it's number nine on my
list and and I actually kind of
struggled with it a little bit because
it's kind of a odd man out in the Marvel
Universe because it doesn't really
connect to Ultron and it doesn't really
seem to connect to Civil War and if the
other movies we don't know that
I think that's the reason with Edgar
left is because Marvel wanted to tie it
in more with the Marvel Cinematic
Universe I don't think that mainstream
audiences know that much about Edgar
Wright to be honest I don't think that
they're gonna sit watch billboards watch
trailers and go oh that's that movie the
Edgar Wright left right nobody cares
they want to see a superhero movie it's
the summer blockbuster season I think
that ant-man is going to be make a ton
of money one movie that I have in my
list that I don't think any of you have
in yours pixels Wow I'm betting on the
Sandman and I might get burned I might
get burned I'm hesitant because that's
Adam Sandler in it yeah but beyond that
I think the concepts concepts cool I
love Josh GAD I love Peter Dinklage I
think there's a lot going for this
freaking Dinklage yeah I'm interested to
see it but I didn't quite get up to the
time let's talk about a film that the
three of you have at number two I have
at number three minions the people love
minions I think if there was gonna be a
movie that could potentially challenge
Ultron for number one it could be
minions I put it at number three with
Jurassic world number two just gambling
on that becoming a phenomenon Amy you
have Jurassic world number five I have
it at five this was tough I went back
and forth a lot with Jurassic world a
mission impossible 5 to me mission
impossible 5 and dress--i crota like the
Battle of the 90s franchises still
fighting it out today and it's like how
much nostalgia is gonna win out and how
much are new kids gonna care either way
if it's great I think it could really be
a phenomenon and go you know it's rocket
if it's mediocre too bad I think it
could open big and then kind of peener
off as it goes now Aaron you don't have
Mission Impossible on your list Amy you
have Mission Impossible as number 4
which one of you is correct I feel like
Tom Cruise doesn't fill seats in
theaters anymore I mean edge of tomorrow
was an awesome movie and not a lot of
people showed up for that I think he's
on an upswing I feel like the
conversation about him is starting to
change I don't think he's at all the
box-office poison people thought he was
I think people cannot stop talking about
that plane thing you could I could see
that 50 times that's good stuff that's
good stuff eat in the trailer over
ever again but now you can see it big
tomorrow and that's another movie that
could potentially appeal to kids maybe
it'll capture adults imaginations dan
let's see where you had Tomorrowland you
have yeah I had it as high as three and
as low as eight or nine this more than
any of the other movies I don't know
what to do with this movie because we
don't we don't know what this movie is
and I think more than the thing that
scares me about Tomorrowland either up
or down as I think more than anything
else on the list it's completely based
on how good the movie yeah I don't know
I just feel like jinx around this movie
I feel like even the studio feels like
this movie is jinx I don't feel like
they're selling it that much yeah it
feels like they're sort of like uh let's
just John Carter this one Melissa
McCarthy's back spy she's teaming up
with Jason Statham Paul Feig that's a
great combo that's a combo thatís worked
several times Amy you have spy at number
seven I do I believe very strongly in
spy there's like so many female comedies
this summer which is really nice to see
actually this is gonna be the one that
people go to nobody's gonna go see the
Reese Witherspoon one I think at all
I think Melissa McCarthy runs into an
issue because she's playing that same
character she always plays in every
movie I feel like that like police
detective thing I think Erin are you
saying that you have McCarthy fatigue
I'm thinking about audiences and the
audience's see this trailer and don't
know why it's any different from any
other Melissa McCarthy movies I've ever
seen and I think that's gonna hurt it I
agree I think it's gonna be good but I
just don't think it's gonna make the
money at the box office when when I was
putting together my list it came down
between spy and Ted two and comedy wise
I just went with Ted 2 I don't know if
it's gonna be nearly as good as the
first one but I think it's gonna do okay
I don't see that many adult comedies so
I wanted to put that one on I think it's
gonna do fine I'm just I'm like it's not
I don't really want to see an animated
they are talking about sperm it's it's
not that fun for me dan you have tattoo
on your leg I do I have it in number
seven as a reluctant number seven
I think this more than how a million
ways to die in the West yes it's gonna
be the verdict on what the public thinks
about Seth MacFarlane who knows maybe
I'll hit like another comedy sequel 22
Jump Street you never know a movie that
I'm excited about but I don't
think it's gonna crack the top ten Mad
Max fury road I know I really was so sad
I wouldn't be in my top ten but I want
it to be so bad but yeah none of us have
it on our list also it's a hard art like
it is gonna be dark and demented and I
don't think that that's necessarily
attractive to so I'll tell you one thing
me likee hard are so me like you do yeah
how come you don't have it on your top
ten cuz I like you and I have talked
about this movie you're excited by this
movie so excited for this movie and
making my list it was the ultimate do I
think with my heart or do I think with
my back and I'm so pumped for Mad Max
and I'm so I know so many other people
that are but when but when I take a step
back and look at it I see Pacific Rim
it has comic-con excited it has you know
the the people that are really into that
kind of thing excited but I don't think
it's gonna have that crossover appeal
especially with an r-rating is hitting
early though which is good but again
there's no marketing mmm-hmm yeah it's
it's coming out so soon the fact that it
isn't more on people's lips besides us
yeah three month or isn't makes me
nervous
what movies do you love we want to see
your top ten list leave us your list in
the comments section below
what are going to be the top ten
domestic grossing films this summer
that's from May 1st to Labor Day let us
know the best list the one who's closest
to the actual list is going to win a
screen junkies t-shirt speaking of
t-shirts check out this cool new t-shirt
we have new screen junkies t-shirts new
honest trailers t-shirts kind of awesome
check out our district lines store the
link is in the description below
and check out this cool panel I want to
thank you for being here Erin Robinson
amy nicholson dan merle follow them all
on twitter hit me up on twitter i'm Hal
Rudnick thanks for watching bye like the
series finale of The Sopranos we got
Tony and his family sitting down for a
nice
mysterious men coming and going and then
what happened is Tony dead